tu es le boss coupe est ce que tu en as
un anneau données sûreté pmp il ya les
négociations qui débutent avec la
rentrée prochaine et il se pourrait bien
que tu es pmp change peut-être de chaîne
à la rentrée demain
oui la lune et à dégager des écoutes va
très bien alors
d'où vous avez eu cette année
même source bah oui pas donnez moi vos
sources parce que moi je vous donnerai
retourner à la source ap
alors c'est quoi c'est quoi et bien déjà
vous allez dire si j'ai tort aussi j'ai
faut bien sûr et les modes ou si
j'habite moi d'où vous avez votre source
dans la garonne la source la gamme a
fait des vagues jaunes
la lie à tous les prof de géo qui
n'engagent
[Rires]
médecin est alors vas-y panucci
journaliste je peux pas dévoiler mes
sources donnent nous ta source ou tu
nous donnes ta source o o ou bien on va
devenir le 10e alors j'ai un truc à dire
jeudi si tu me donnes ta source je
t'offre montbozon haut
[Applaudissements]
il est comme un fou sombre je rajoute
mon slip
attendent que je suis à
présent dans sois tu adores art est
dominé par ma taille salut mais c'est le
même en plus petit ah ouais j'aurais
pris 2,20 pour mon fils et comme tu veux
je te jure que c'est vrai et je tapais
j'ai ris je rigole pas j'en ai recensé 2
x est ce donc non non non non non oli de
sat avec petit jeu peut aller que de
faire chercher tout de suite à des
essais nos vaches balas la source
du monde est sans doute viola a acheté
explique ainsi moitié moi j'écris une
parole
malheureusement j'en ai qu'une
si tu me dit la source tu auras ton
blues ont juste après le chèque est de
combien le poison si nous on sait où
tarbes louvain comme ça j'explique ça
qu'il est beau alors
non mais j'ai une déontologie
journalistique je pense
aux colonies
on n'a plus de voix bien je vous dirai
pas qui c'est mais je n'ai attendu à
loches voilà non non il faut qu'on les
côtoie date les mangas je vais te
laisser quatre minutes comprend ta
décision on va aller chercher le blouson
et à la maison c'est juste à côté ah non
mais le coup de pression là
tu connais mes méthodes danoun hors
jeu le blouson sera là il sera à portée
de main tu verras et j'espère que tu ne
donneras un nom et si le non se trouve
ici parmi les chroniqueurs bien entendu
cette personne disparue du rachat qui
est de sa témérité des missions très pnp
va-t-elle changer de chaîne à la rentrée
c'est la bombe qu'a lancé clément garin
hier dans l'émission de valérie bénaïm
des pmp xxl clément garenq a dit qu'on
allait aller sur canal canal + j'ai
ramené la chaîne qui est la chaîne a
milité dans le groupe canal séparément
qu'on va aller sur ses stars
non mais oh ça va on adore ses stars
mais bon c'est pas le moment c'est pas
tout à fait tout cas pas tout de suite
on a le temps d'y aller oui oui oui oui
alors alors la source
voilà veste qui qui supprime j'ai joué
ma vie je n'occupe est non mais j'ai
changé d'avis donne pas le nom
bah moi je veux dire la vérité m'a donné
pendant les pubs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la banda s'est plus fait ça lui aurait
remis d'aplomb et un peu noël
mamère ont confirmé qu'ils étaient à
l'entrée donc du coup dans le groupe
canada tony chapron négociations je peux
confirmer qu'un jour c'est en
négociations on reprend là dessus on
inventerait sinon même plein temps de me
dire c'est que randy saint-alme mon
l'instant pas donné le nom c'est agatha
la productrice et pptx m agata que vous
retrouverez sur d'autres productions
non mais voilà et donc n'annonce une
amie donc voila mais est en jeu et
agathe un
mois l extra alors dit moi et ben du
coup mais vous allez confirmer ou
infirmer l'information si vous pouviez
l'a confirmé ça m'arrangerait vous met
il en arrive en avril il ya toujours les
tractations les discussions et il se
pourrait que vous finissiez sur canal+ à
la base et vous finissiez alors je
voulais à la limite mais je vais vous
dire la vérité
c'est très clair on sera
sur une chaîne à la banque
[Rires]
il n'y a même plus on sera en direct sur
une chaîne à la rentrée
2008 heures 40 jusqu'à 21h15 toulalan à
18h jusqu'à 21h15 toujours à me plaire
toujours en clair voilà est toujours
dans ce groupe toujours dans ce groupe
alors c'est très simple puisque à la
rentrée je vous le redis
et jeudi au chroniqueur parce que qui
dit changement de chaîne qui bien sûr
augmentation oui mais attention à bien
sûr augmentation ces réductions de
personnes à leur augmentation si on
change de chaîne bien entendu
augmentation pour fêter cela donc les
chéris sachez
que vous ne serez pas augmenté
on reste bien entendu sur ces 8 me
et je vous le redis pour l'instant dans
canal+ france en service vraiment sûr il
ya énormément de foot sur canal donc si
on doit se caler sur le foot c'est à
dire qu'on fait des missions deux fois
par semaine forcément c'est un peu ccp
gagner mais c'est vrai que voilà on
adore canal mais on est très très bien
sûr c'est vite et voilà on fera encore
on sera encore là la saison prochaine
j'espère que vous êtes content de le
savoir mais on sera la saison prochaine